Hello everybody welcome to another week
of good gaming news this is a news show
where I talk about all of the good news
to come out of the games industry
because there are enough people on
YouTube talking about the bad news even
though there's a place for that just
trying to vary it um also I'm recording
this live on Twitch for the first time
so there's the twitch chat uh not a ton
of big stories this week for things that
are good news so we're starting with
something that's obviously very small
this comes from gamatsu.com and is
Silent Hill the short message rated in
Korea there have been so many Silent
Hill rumors over the last 10 years I
mean since PT obviously
um it's like every few months there's
something new and I got so upset at the
game awards last year when people kept
saying Silent Hill I think even Del Toro
did which was infuriating but yet I keep
getting excited by them so we're still
here obviously so this one of all the
rumors that have come out recently
actually probably seemed the most
legitimate to me
uh the story says the game rating ad
Administration Committee of Korea has
rated the unannounced Silent Hill the
short message platforms were not
specified and this is a screenshot of it
here
the publisher is listed as uni Anna
which regularly publishes Konami games
in Korea Konami is free to play soccer
game e football 2023 published by uniana
was also included in today's batch of
Korean game ratings but that's generally
all we've got from this particular story
is just a reading that's an update that
is enough for me to want to take it
uh it's very little but I do feel like
it's likely that this is on the horizon
I mean it's just people care way too
much about this IP for somebody to not
be working on it it's almost impossible
and I think I've said this in videos
before I didn't make a video about it
but what I heard about Silent Hill
years and years ago
um was from a source that I no longer
trust they ended up lying about other
stuff so I wouldn't be surprised if they
also lied to me but I'm still going to
tell you what I heard anyway because
it's interesting if you haven't already
heard me talk about it what I had heard
was that the Silent Hill sorry it would
be Silent Hills
um would interact with you outside of
the game it would send you text messages
the game would send you emails if you
had smart lighting
um based on you giving it permissions to
[ __ ] with your Wi-Fi it would be able to
[ __ ] with your lights potentially and in
order to be able to do some of that
stuff uh the idea was that you would
have to sign a wave yet a lot of that
doesn't make sense in theory
um sorry in practice but I can see that
being something that Kojima would think
about but that is what I had last heard
and I imagine realistically that whole
thing has probably been scrapped
um and that yeah we're likely getting a
game from blueber Team maybe we'll see
more of the game awards I would really
like to I think that would be great next
up unsurprisingly Google stadia has come
to a close and there's a lot of bad in
this news and some good in this news the
main thing I think is that stadia was
like almost never going to work I will
say I actually had a pretty good
experience with Stadium when I first
played it but that's in La that's in La
is such a like specific environment uh
it was at home I guess I would have been
near a data center it ran well for me I
was able to stream it and I also think
they really [ __ ] up the release this
is a really poor release it didn't work
for way too many people it should have
been easy access it should have been
advertised as a beta the way that they
released it does it it was just a
disaster
um so here is some good news that's come
out of the closure of stadia I will
cover the bad news just to give you the
context of it but what is stadia was the
only console ever
to offer refunds
basically on everything right
this is from polygon it says has
anything in video game launched horror
and returned to the Earth harder than
Google stadia I don't think stadia
launched hot uh goes on to say in the
end perhaps the only Innovation Google
will offer to video gaming is the idea
that when a platform well and truly dies
folks who put skin into their games can
expect some money back Google will shut
down stadia for good on January 18 2023
anything other than stadia Pro
subscriptions will be refunded Wild
though whether that's automatic or needs
to be claimed is unknown right now those
who bought stadia's full price games
expansions or downloadable content will
be compensated Google said on Thursday
just like
unheard of positive news that I hope
could maybe set a Precision I doubt it
to be honest
but if this is something that anybody
follows that to win if even one company
in the games industry is like okay we
should think about that for any of their
streaming services
to allow things to be refundable it just
feels like one of those things that we
should be talking about very very
positively everyone's obviously [ __ ]
on steady all the time there are a lot
of things wrong with it it failed
um but if we can scream about how good
this is get more of this particular
thing
my gosh this is really cool UB stuff
will let you transfer your stadia
purchases to PC if you bought nubisoft a
Ubisoft I guess and because it's a vowel
your body Ubisoft game on the soon to be
discontinued cloud gaming platform
you'll be able to get a copy on PC
again I think this is actually really
good news uh it says stadia may be
shutting down next year but if you've
purchased UB subtitles on the cloud
gaming platform you'll be able to
transfer those purchases to PC at some
point in the future leave yourself
confirmed to The Verge well Sandy will
shut down on January 18th 2023 we're
happy to share that we're currently
working to bring the games you own on
stadia to PC through Ubisoft connect
we'll have more to share regarding
specific details as well as the impact
for Ubisoft plus subscribers at a later
date so
yeah I just really wanted to share this
um so people know so people are aware of
it it just feels like something that
should be spoken about should be covered
in some way
even if it is like actually very bad
news it's good for people to advocate
for themselves generally several
developers have voice concerns following
the announcement of stadia's closure as
they were not given prior notice that's
nuts uh yesterday Google announced it
say we'll be shutting down in January
2023 but for many developers the Public
Announcement was the first they heard
about it Maya developers Simon Roth
tweeted that it was months of his work
going in the bin again adding that he
wasn't given any prior notice every time
something bad happens in games the
people affected sometimes having their
lives turned upside down learn from the
press or Twitter no emails phone calls
no heads up no note on the website
that is like
unbelievably disrespectful uh clearly he
added that he doesn't know anyone doing
stadia stuff right now who has heard
anything more than what the Press has
further down his story she had a
screenshot from another Twitter user
showing that Google staff were allegedly
only told about the closure three hours
before the Public Announcement other
developers have shared similar stories
with sfb games's tombayan saying on
Twitter that tangle Tower is due to
release on stadia tomorrow and an
article from The Verge announcing
Stadium's closure was the first he heard
about it shutting down so being that
this is way too hopeful but being that
Google
is refunding all-stadia purchases made
through the Google store
which rules
I would very much like to hear Google
follow up with some kind of action or
clarification for the dev teams who got
dropped
obviously they don't have to do that I
don't imagine that there are contracts
requiring that I don't imagine that
legally there's anything binding them to
doing that or any real reason that they
will I'm just hopeful again
the refunds thing is unprecedented and
awesome I love that it would be very
very nice to see
um support for devs too obviously
because that is just unbelievable to not
give people more of a heads up so that
they can at least protect their IP is a
huge part of it so
absolutely wild so this is also pretty
minor
but we got some more insight from EA on
uh Dead Space remaking a classic
and I just wanted to shout this out
because I think what they're doing here
is really cool
um what EA's been doing with both skate
and Dead Space especially on last week's
episode of this exact show I spoke about
uh just wishing that devs could be a bit
more transparent about processes I do
kind of also feel like they've been
doing that with Splinter Cell
um Ubisoft obviously with Splinter Cell
so this is basically an update on Dead
Space um that they call inside dead
space and it's just kind of uh
information about rebuilding the game
from scratch and adding new content and
modern enhancements into the mix but
never ever portraying the original just
love the transparency love to get these
kind of updates that aren't inside of
like a highly marketed uh packaged
trailer reel Sizzle reel it just it's
just a really nice change of pace for
the industry surprisingly coming from EA
specifically and it all sounds really
really promising
um it still feels a little weird to me
to remake Dead Space when I feel like
Dead Space 1 still plays so well but
everything they're saying here is really
appealing to me so I'm sure other fans
will probably feel the same way so uh
first we honor the Legacy says senior
producer Philippe Duchamp we look at the
original game with the utmost respect so
the core foundations will remain the
same however we are making several
enhancements to the experience to make
it enticing for both new players and
returning ones the screenshot there
represents game in development I mean
the lighting looks beautiful
and I think Dead Space
has some of the best sound design I
would still say of any game the sound
design and Dead Space keeps it
terrifying even if you go and play dead
space now it's still like can show me to
my core so adding the new Lighting on
there
I'm just I'm just very excited to see it
um to play it really I don't even need
to see it I know they're dropping a new
trailer pretty soon I believe it's next
week the fourth I think is when they
said um so keep an eye out for that I
will see uh to help ensure that happened
the team took the unusual step of
reaching out to the hardest of the
hardcore fans as advisors creating a
community council to bounce ideas off of
which is also kind of fun out of really
really early in development Romans says
we started discussions with some members
of the community who were identified by
our team as Die Hard fans
we met with them every six weeks roughly
and we gave them full access to what we
were doing
that's really cool surprising to me yeah
as they said here this is not common and
it isn't at all common
no it's David in fact in my experience
it's very rare I've only seen a few
other titles do something like this and
I don't know why it's very rare because
it seems like every time you do it you
get really good results go figure right
I guess it's probably because they're
worried about people leaking things or
breaking into you because we have our
opinions but that doesn't mean we're
right for leap ads there are a number of
polarizing topics we wanted to get a gut
check on so we gathered feedback from
these groups to make informed decisions
a focus on community is one of the key
pillars of this project so we also took
feedback from our live streams read
through user reviews and twitch comments
there was a lot of intake of information
it was all to understand who we're
addressing with this game and what made
Dead Space spectacular to them the
result is a game that's much more than a
simple modernization of the original the
story for example hits all the main
beats and main events of the original
but we looked at the lore of the whole
franchise which is a lot wider than the
original game it was Dead Space 2 and
Dead Space 3 the comic books these all
added additional law that we've
re-injected into the game which also
sounds pretty cool to me depending on
how they injected them they tried to fit
the overall story in law of the Dead
Space Universe that evolved after just
the first one which makes me wonder if
maybe they're not going to be remaking
two and three probably I would also
think that this means um that we'll get
a new Dead Space game as well we'll
probably get Dead Space 4 if this sells
well they're testing the waters to see
how everything's going uh of course
there are serious technological
enhancements that Modern Hardware
provides it's new engine frostbite
and every asset every animation every
texture every effect or piece of enemy
Behavior
has been rebuilt in the new engine it's
really cool side by side there I mean it
looks miles better
that looks great we're also actually
creating the entire game as one
sequential shot you're doing a God of
War I didn't know that
from the moment you start the game to
the moment you end the game there are no
camera Cuts or load screens unless you
die okay God of War that's cool I did
not know that the issue mirror is now
fully interconnected so you can walk
from point A to point B to point Z sorry
visit the entire ship and revisit
locations you've already completed to
pick up things you might have missed
that's all new it's now completely
unbroken experience that's really cool
that is really really cool how you move
around in zero g is also something we
felt or we could improve in terms of
experience and immersion romances so
there's much more 360 degree Freedom now
when you play dead space you feel like
you're in space this also allows us to
revisit some of the old content and
create new ways to navigate new pods and
new environments with new challenges
that's neat I feel like updates on zero
g could potentially mean some
interesting side quest stuff um I love
the zero g stuff in Dead Space I
actually felt like that was very good in
Dead Space 3 which did some other things
probably most Dead Space fans didn't
like so much but the zero g Parts like
actually flying outside the [ __ ] I
thought were really cool and with the
computational power we have now we're
able to push lighting much much much
further that's clear from the
screenshots I think uh both from a pure
lighting perspective and also a
shadowing perspective and appealing and
dismemberment system we have now is
really cool and it adds quite a bit to
our gameplay feels more Dynamic more
strategic that's cool if you can get
more specific with your dismembering
which again I feel like Dead Space 3
escalated
I love that it was a very fun part of it
right when you start shooting you see
the skin and flesh getting ripped from
the enemy's body then you can start to
see the bones underneath and then you
can cut the bones and it cuts the limb
and so on
oh my gosh it looks amazing but it also
gives direct feedback to the player
about the amount of damage they're doing
which is obviously really important in a
game like Dead Space
which has a very limited UI overall
though we want to make sure people
understand that we're not just going in
and enhancing the graphics as Philippe
although that would have been amazing on
its own but it's also the addition of
all the new content leadership law that
kind of depth to create a new and
enhanced experience I have high hopes
for this game okay the last story this
week
because I love covering a good mod I
think I mentioned this in one of these
videos before but I used to cover mods
professionally like I'd try them out and
then rank them every week and so I still
have a lot of fondness for them even if
I don't use them very much these days
but this one I'm a big Far Cry 2 person
this rules
Far Cry 2 mod revitalizes and improves
the old classic and I do fully think
that Far Cry 2 is aged poorly it is kind
of tough to play even though I would
consider it to be like
I mean I love Far Cry 3 but like Far Cry
2 is good in a different way okay
uh one of the oldest Far Cry games on
the market has just received a new set
of hugely impressive mods as part of Far
Cry 2 realism and redo release though
the game was initially panned for some
of its questionable gameplay decisions
malaria Far Cry 2 eventually became a
cult classic and since diff is so much
from and since it differs so much from
every other game in the series it still
stands on its own two feet
when Far Cry franchises certainly moved
on from provide while the Far Cry
franchise has certainly moved on from
providing an overly immersive and
Hardcore gameplay experience in lieu of
something more universally acclaimed
fans of Far Cry 2 specifically never
received a true follow-up to the
experience which is true to that end the
full release of realism and redo plus
redo I'm just assuming that's not Redux
it could be I I don't actually know how
to say that word I've only read it
before who [ __ ] knows to that end the
full release of this mod provides an
easy and comprehensive set of upgrades
to virtually every aspect of the 2008
title I feels like it was further away
than that to be honest
uh since it seems that Far Cry 2 won't
get a remake anytime soon it definitely
won't
mod is going by the names Fox Head
Hunter and Tom have joined voice voices
have joined forces to release what is in
effect a massive collection of systemic
gameplay upgrades for Far Cry 2. not
only have Graphics been substantially
improved across the board but users can
also expect vastly improved physics
that's awesome
that's really cool proper support for 60
frames per second gameplay and better
textures gameplay wise all Weaponry has
been thoroughly rebalanced with enhanced
AI nice less oppressive anime checkpoint
respawns nice that was definitely one of
the biggest issues with Far Cry 2 it was
ridiculous you'd like walk down the
street kill five dudes turn a corner I
would be like oh should I drop something
turn back and the same five dudes are
there again it was absurd
um love to see that upgrade father
improvements can be seen in the game
world too where all the disparate
changes come together to deliver an
improved gameplay sandbox with more
reactive and realistic enemies across
the board that's awesome yeah just like
stoked that somebody did this I don't
know I just don't feel like we deserve
them
it's very very very cool yeah just
unpaid like work that's very like
thankless to be honest and improving Far
Cry 2 is awesome like I have so much
love for that game but I'm not going to
deny that the issues with it were really
really big issues and again I really do
love Far Cry 3 as well so I am happy to
hear it happy that these people doing
these things exist
happy to have another week of good
gaming news I'll see you next week
everybody bye